welcome to another episode of not too
deep it's a very exciting episode I'm
your host grace Helbig we are officially
formally launching our monthly Mitchell
episode he is back with us he lives in
the floor but we're bringing him up for
air once a month from here until he
bails on me we have a Grayson Mitchell I
guess ranty kind of episode we talk
about things that we don't like he
explains to me what being an emo kid
actually entails and turns out it's a
very luxurious difficult
high-maintenance lifestyle enjoy this
episode of not too deep wait the one
they only Mitchell Davis you ever gotten
a public massage for sure really that's
one thing I can't bring myself to do it
he always goes Express buzz in the
airport
oh I can't do it those are my sheesh
really yes see I feel like a full on
performance artist narcissist in the
airport Oh in the airport maybe you're
the best massages I've ever had really
yeah because they just don't give a [ __ ]
no look true and also it's the most
vulnerable I've ever seen someone in
public just facedown in the middle of a
[ __ ] hallway with people who are all
stressed out in your life yeah I know I
mean I mean I will just be like you know
my bags are heavy get in there bro
get in there bro he's like you don't
even have luggage did sometimes I'll
just go to the airport for massage suck
it up through TSA just to get these
quads in order and I just get one of
those 59.99 Vegas passes just for a good
masseuse welcome I welcome this I mean
Mitchell this is your one hundred and
fiftieth time one hundred and fifty
seventh time on the podcast
yeah I did forget those six yeah we all
wanted to forget that yeah yeah we were
like we gotta get this guy out of here
the we are now officially formally
committing to a monthly episode in which
you are my co-host no that's that's I
mean we visit we've been
with that idea for a long time and I
think we're actually gonna jump in dive
in we commit to the relationship put it
out like that it makes me nervous other
shows totally differently maybe my arms
don't work on the ad breaks we'll get
you a massage don't worry I did
yesterday for questions oh I trust me
yeah I got a lot of I was in that yeah
you put me in that tweet and I got every
single buzz you got every little
notification every notification some
were so bizarre I literally turn to my
friend Emily I was just like is this do
you think this is what Grace's Twitter's
like oh I realized that when I asked for
questions for people in the podcast
there's a lot of repetitive questions or
a lot of just like the same type of like
what got you started on YouTube what's
what's your biggest regret any advice
for someone going to college like stuff
like that that we've answered a billion
times and so when I start being more
direct and say send me your dumbest most
invasive questions people really take it
upon themselves yeah they do they really
really do yeah I mean and they also just
make a lot of callbacks that I'm just I
was just scrolling through my feet and I
was just having just just triggers all
over the place of our past theocracies
yeah we've done so much we've made and
created so much content together yeah
when I see someone referencing something
specific I have no memory of it
there are a few that in the picture you
post I was like when did we take oh my
god I live with just google image search
it was like I look like Chris Kindle she
has the same color hair is me I don't
know what the [ __ ] going on look like
twins ya know like it's the one picture
you could have posted where people like
maybe they've been related this whole
time we've been bamboozled yeah it was a
literally like looked at the picture
trestles like I don't [ __ ] remember
yeah
we look like we're doing hard drugs in
that phone yeah we are like we are like
so stoic you guys haven't seen it go
back through my Twitter and find it it's
um yeah surprisingly it's like the first
photo that comes up when I googled it
great I'm glad that that's a part of
completely random forgettable photo that
looks like children of the corn found an
iPhone yes it looks like we're looking
at a camera for the first time it's like
an 1800s picture yeah it's a really good
I'm gonna frame it put at my house it's
very good makes me want to go back and
deep dive and look through because
that's before people really kind of
curated their selfies
no it definitely was we just didn't give
a [ __ ] it's really good we were still
just posting my life is a buzz out there
just killing it on a beach like we found
a four rectangle with light but I also
asked for people to give us suggestions
on maybe what we should call these
episodes yes they're gonna be a little
bit more niche and a little bit more
formatted ish in that the only format is
that you're here kind of hoping you're
gonna say formal and I was like cool
we're gonna wear suit we're gonna wear
two tuxedos cool but I did like Alan
sheared responded that he thinks that we
should at least have a segment called
save us Davis save us Davis oh wow
that's great
we're actually tips on how to be a
decent human being every episode this
segment is introduced but the only thing
he ever says is quote just be nice to
people and don't be a dick and then the
segment is over that is not only did
Alan give us a suggestion he is written
out the entire that's awesome you did
all the work for us though that's so
great
Alan you said you got a way shirt dude
you got a that's not how you're giving
away good ideas
and I just take it I just want to put
out there though cuz it was on my mind I
just everybody should just be what was
it again that's what I was thinking just
organically it's just being nice to
people and don't be a dick give the lion
good dance there's time to work on Ali
here every month yeah I'll try next
month follow Joss just said how is this
different I ask myself that every day
when I wake up I look in the mirror I go
how is this different
a lot of people have like motivational
things that's my man yeah you are not
getting your down payment no yeah that's
crazy
they also said I kid I suggest you call
them remembrances of YouTube past how I
decided on this haircut though I mean I
feel like we're at our hair peaks right
now I think yeah I think we have come
into our own hair wise I know I am yeah
you have definitely I mean from the
photo that I posted to right now really
how to blow up as the kid say just in
just hair alone yeah you know not the
rest of me the rest is still exactly
that same photo but the hair itself yeah
I don't know what happened I just got
struck by lightning yeah and where's I
last time I was just wearing a helmet
yeah full Beatle so be fair though you
cheat you do change your hair quite a
bit you've gone through a lot of looks I
think you Luke's in the loosest sense
yeah I've gone through some emotional
turmoil I think yeah more appropriate
for how the looks of happy Scott pill we
all have to Scott Pilgrim sometimes and
just cut our hair or let it grow and
just throw on that beanie Oh what are
you watching right now what am i
watching I'm looking at you watching um
I just I just started watching anime for
the first time in first time ever ever
ever you never see I would pay you as an
enemy boy
okay first off I'm grace I don't feel
comfortable you saying you'd beg me but
yeah yeah I a lot of people always
assumed that I would be really into it
and stuff I mean the closest I had ever
come was like Venture Brothers or
anything like right right but uh yeah I
just started recently watching some
stuff yeah which one got broke the seal
is this it's like this scary one I don't
know the name exactly so yeah go check
it out but I know it's scary there's
there's a story about like a girl who
basically turns into a slug and it's so
like it's so specific that I know that
you if you google that you're gonna find
it is it it's nice to be like a metaphor
in any way I don't know they're just
terrifying like there was an episode
where a dude was just like like he was
like it's part of our tradition and I'm
spoiling this episode's tradition of our
family is to pass down the memories of
our loved ones and then you find out
that they're just like attaching each
others like old head piece of head right
to like their uh their existing head and
it looks like a giant caterpillar like
it's very terrifying graphics and uh
yeah I like it I've also been watching
this thing called like hunter hunter or
something I don't know just that it's
like this kid who's just like he wants
to be like a hunt just like of the
ultimate a hunter in this world and is
it a reality show no this is another
anime oh okay you're still spiked up
okay I don't even know if that's all
happens but I'm serious you guys guys
it's all the hairs like real hi I love
it but how did you decide that you were
gonna get into anime I watched a YouTube
video where someone was telling the
anime is one of the few formats where
they can get away with more expression
in the face and I was I was interested
in seeing it happen in thing cuz they
were saying like you can mute it and
like their pupils will shake when
they're like worried or they're thinking
and also that like they're more
expressive and everybody you can kind of
hear their thoughts and the storytelling
is just different in anime and I was
just interested to see it and
you're in it I think I'm hooked you're
into it a minute
it's Dragon Ball Z anime I think so okay
I mean again I'm new so you know
everything I just said there's probably
like a lot of people listening just
cringe screaming yeah they're like
screaming us are like can I get that cuz
I you know I that was like my whole high
school career yeah everything he's
saying is wrong yes yeah that's cool
this new world what are you watching oh
I'm I watched The Bachelor this week I'm
caught up okay
it's been a slow season yeah I know
offense it's sucked hard I'm not gonna
lie I know it's been a slow season I
don't watch it because I don't hear
about it on Twitter right well this past
episode this will come out you know a
month or so after this most recent
episode finally it was interesting he
basically a virgin this way he oh you
know if he wanted 10 seconds of one
episode you'll find out pretty quickly
20 times that he's a virgin I just wanna
let you guys know as the first virgin
I'm a virgin virgin virgin virgin can I
get a virgin marks height or more virgin
like I'm gonna need some aversion
therapy after this yeah it's not a good
season and they harp so hardly on the
fact that he is a virgin that it's like
never done sex yeah and you almost feel
like maybe you feel a little like
creeped out that these girls have to be
like I'm gonna maybe be the one that
takes us publicly like things away from
him it's so weird but then he basically
just lost his actual mind this most
recent episode he's done the three girls
and he told one that he wants her and
she's like I'm actually kind of out Oh
like oh I talked to my dad he knows that
I have hesitation so I don't think I can
be here and so he like broke the [ __ ]
down yeah that's that's what you do and
then he jumped a fence and ran into the
woods and Chris Harrison doesn't know
where he is right now
Wow I know good TV that it actually is
took so many episodes to get to this
yeah it's the fence jump we've all been
waiting for and they've been teasing it
since the first trailer okay okay I have
some shows that aren't anime that I'm
not gonna butcher you ready yep pin 15
oh that's the one I have to watch yeah
Rhett stable yeah and I said
and crustal it's incredible it's so good
so so good and I love that the two main
characters are actually adults really
yeah I don't see I only know when it's
about middle school I loved it I loved
the umbrella brigade
I felt awesome that's a gerard ways like
graphic novel turned to life on netflix
cool cool it was very cool
i truly say the music was the best part
soundtrack is just so good
cool check it out yeah someone wants us
to rant about Aquaman did you see
Aquaman no but let's let's actually ran
him out this yeah I just I already
rented on Murray night's podcast about
this but I got playing in no no I'm
sorry I'm sorry I mean I know where he
gets dreams here I got a lot to say
about Aquaman first of all Torrey like
this season of The Bachelor sucks a dick
no sense I mean he is fantastic
you saw it I paid money at a movie
theater to see I went to an I pick
treated myself Wow Chester and I went
and won had the weirdest experience of
all time with the bartender we went
early and went to the bar before we went
into the movie theater that's also a bar
yeah and we went and ordered drinks and
like an appetizer from the bartender a
completely empty bar maybe two other
people there not busy shining so a guy
asked us to repeat our order immediately
and we did and then he went to the he's
like kiosk thing and he rang it up and
then he just went over and poured
himself a cup of coffee and was just
sipping coffee like ten feet to our left
we were like was performance I thought
we were being pranked I was like are we
in the hidden-camera show right now
what's going on and then like literally
three minutes passed because we're like
let's give him the benefit of the doubt
maybe this is how he makes drinks and
finally came over and he's like your
apps are gonna be out soon we're like
what about the rum and coke and the
vodka soda and he goes oh shoot yeah
okay I got some eggs this might have
been Bill Murray the most confusing
bartending experience
I've had in a very long time I was just
like I know that I'm not I wasn't a good
server when I was you know waiting
tables but this is exceptionally bad we
gave you two of the easiest drinks I
mean it and what's even crazier is just
like I give complicated drink sometimes
in bars that it's just like music it's
just bass and I'm still just like he's
like got it
got it do you want to start it tap I
know but like right then what confusing
dick energy for someone to take your
drink order have you repeated yeah and
then just walk very slowly over and pour
themselves a cup of coffee yeah I feel
like that's so that was how that was my
appetizer to going to see Aquaman cool
so you were already like pretty jazz I
was already in a silly state it was
terrible I just and we couldn't help but
laugh the whole time and then when you
get into that when you realize like this
movie's gonna suck the whole time but
all I can do is laugh at it that so it
was like an hour and a half of just
going how did this happen
I mean okay so it's all underwater a lot
of it yeah until the time when they have
to save themselves and they get on a
boat somehow and the boat gets in an
accident and then they're [ __ ] but
they're creatures that survive
underwater I don't understand why the
boat is the thing that they need to
survive if anything they [ __ ] that the
boat would if the boat fell apart they'd
be like oh no we're falling there where
we come from essentially they are to
human boats I don't know why they needed
an actual tangible boat
yeah that sounds weird yeah it also
turns into like Mamma Mia for a second
cuz they go to Italy and it's like she's
Aquagirl girl that's a love interest has
I've never been on land before even
though she has and so she turned the
might be aerial situation where she's
like going around the fountains and like
eating a flower because she doesn't know
how human food works and it's so if
you're hit he's a superhero and he eats
the flower to to make her not feel weird
and he's a superhero both get the shits
I bet have you ever eaten a flower well
that's just my personal experience I ate
a flower once and I got the shit's what
are we talking about yeah Aquaman I do
it's um what's the movie you've seen
lately that bothered you that bothered
me yeah
Oh Oh I was a lackluster slightly a
disappointment
oh my phone really quick yeah cuz that I
never go see movies ever we all know
this but then to go and see this movie
was like I'm gonna give it the benefit
of the doubt and it really I was kind of
excited about thinking about what's the
last movie that I was like this is Garbo
because that [ __ ] happens all the damn
time you know what really kinda I was
like what's going on yeah is that I was
really hoping would be also was that
Bohemian Rhapsody movie oh I heard I
haven't seen it but I've heard my mom
loved it and I was like mom all I've
heard is negative stuff about I didn't
like I get it I get it
but the whole time it just felt like it
was like a moments like they just had
like text on the screen I was like
flying across and they had like a lot of
montage moments and stuff and I was just
like it feels like somebody made this an
iMovie in these parts all the money went
into this one character and then they're
like what we've got the rest of the
movie to make now oh no and it's like a
lot of montages [ __ ] and that's why when
it went editing I was like it won and
it's right it wasn't like editing or
something and I was just like what
that's the what's it's the one thing
that I walked away being like what did I
just like what and the fact is I hardly
ever noticed editing in a movie but you
notice it in a negative way and then
have it win for that and I and I look
I'm in no way like a professional editor
but I edit Oh quite a say this opens the
door for you next year yeah I was just
like there's just some moments where I
was just like that's the best way this
is the intro to some kids like Queen
thing and I'm like wow but I will say
the the whole live a performance at the
end was pretty great I heard that's
really cool but it also just feels a
little like odd that they really played
with us it's like shot-for-shot right
yeah it yeah it is there's like some
YouTube videos of them side by side and
you're just like he studied like he
really he studied that character yeah he
was like I can't imagine they'd like the
choreography of the no choreography like
to make it look like he's just coming up
with these moves all over
totally well--that's after the movie
came out and I heard negative things I
showed Elliott Live Aid on YouTube like
the whole 20 minute performance cuz he
had never seen it before and I just got
so [ __ ] jazzed about it it's an
amazing performance I mean like just
that alone and that's why like I was
like they have to it's gotta be in the
movie it's just yeah in the midst of
iconic and can you imagine I mean just
looking at the crowd and how many
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people that are there and knowing that
they're all paying attention to you is
the most insane thing to my whole body
clinch thinking about yeah my whole body
turned into a puckered butthole I just
can't even talk about it yeah I'm really
nervous but I'm genuinely nervous and
that happened he's so like like the
euros born maybe I don't know well on
you know on the visual imagery of a
puckered butthole we're gonna take a
quick break and when we get back we're
gonna answer some questions submitted
from the social media platform that some
might call the puckered butthole of the
internet twitter we'll be right back
Mitchell Davis on not to do this episode
not too deep is brought you by hum
nutrition hum attrition is all about
making you look and feel your best each
specific supplement packs a combo of
potent ingredients designed for specific
aims like clearer skin boosted energy or
fuller hair and is backed by clinical
results hum focuses on preventing
concerns and long-term care and repair
not damage control and covering up their
quote inside out approach to beauty goes
beyond a skin care regimen alone to give
you great results hums products are
sustainably sourced non-gmo and free of
soy gluten artificial colors and
preservatives plus lots of vegan options
something for everyone
try supplements like the daily cleanse
hair sweet hair growth gummies uber
energy and more if you aren't sure what
you need go to humm nutrition calm slash
get underscore started to take a quiz
and get personalized recommendations
from hums team of registered dieticians
to make things even easier hum offers a
monthly vitamin subscription that's
affordable flexible and
convenient these guys are great every
time I go into a grocery store or any
sort of like supplement sort of Mecca
I'm overwhelmed with possibilities so
the idea of taking their quiz and
getting specific directional treatments
things that you need for you without
wasting your time and taking a bunch of
maybe placebos is perfect go to hummock
nutrition calm / get underscore started
for your personalized recommendations
and get 20% off your purchase with code
grace that's humm nutrition calm / get
underscore started and code grace she
might say that this is a lie but i
verbatim remember this happening okay
she was like Mitchell you know it's so I
was like how does DVDs work how are they
not like VHS is and she goes well the
thing is is they're they're moving on a
disk and it's like burned in there and
the trick so that you can't steal it
Mitchell is they only play once and I
remember going and she's like when you
rent them you can only play them once or
twice and in them and then the movies
gone and then they bring it back and
they like they load it with another
movie and I even as a kid I was like I
think this is wrong
did she genuinely believe that or no she
was actually straight up lying to you
this is the thing I still don't know but
we were in a Hollywood video when it
happened and for that that whole I was I
think it was like a 48-hour thing until
I ran into my friend is her name's like
you're wrong that that's like saying all
video like what no yours dude no as soon
as you brought up video games I was like
you're so right we've been using discs
forever but yeah I I don't know she's
[ __ ] with me but it was it got it
good yeah I mean obviously you still
think about it yeah I know it's not real
but everyone I'm like this DVD could
give thing about like parents
grandparents any sort of adult that has
influence over a child it's a you can
truly tell a child anything at that age
she could have been like hey we don't do
we don't say Z anymore and I've been
like why
don't say it the letter B is a bad word
okay I guess that's Josh yeah I've said
this before that funniest thing Chester
told me one time that his mom when he
was younger told him don't jump on the
bed cuz there might be scissors in the
bed that's tearing and jumping like on a
hotel bed or anything because he thinks
it is he's been trained that there might
be stroke scissors in the back okay
that's [ __ ] awesome that's the only
kind of redeemable quality to me about
being a parent is that you get to [ __ ]
with your kids like that I was just at
like a little house party and somebody
brought one of their kids
it wasn't like crazy we were all just
hanging out watching movies but this kid
started to run into the laundry room and
the dad instantly goes don't go in there
monsters live in there and I turned to
him and I was like you know twenty
twenty years from now this is why your
daughter never does laundry it's
traumatized by a laundry machine so you
can teach child so many things by just
dangling the idea of a monster like I in
front of I just can't it was like
instinctive a disease like sorry I just
say monsters you and I don't want that
baby to go his mom was a little off when
he was growing up and she told them that
they can't put their hands into cereal
boxes because they might be knives in
their say cuz it's gross yeah she was
like she didn't want them eating like
zero with their hands so she told them
that there's knives in the bottom of the
box they couldn't go hang out at the
lake in their town because there was a
witch that lived in the bottom of the
lake nor did he play at the lake okay we
need a children's book written by this
person it's like like maybe child abuse
but the Millenial Hansel and Gretel okay
series is scary
so at the bottom of the lake that's so
specific that's the [ __ ] that you can
see like like that movie woman in the
water something you're like there's
anything growing up I guess just that
like Jesus please teach grace how to be
emo
but in the most cringy way possible
Thanks okay okay you genuinely went
through an emo phase yeah yeah you were
like textbook yeah emo yes emotional
mm-hmm person yep
at some point your life do you think
you're out of that phase I think it's
still deep down in there yeah hey you
never fully be out I think it's just
like you know I'm like a one of those
candy I'm just got coatings over me okay
and I'm like a jawbreaker but the core
still gummy bear you know I mean how do
you describe emo in your opinion I'm
gonna have to okay having have to do
some like serious
16 year old soul surgery okay you're
talking to 16 year old Mitchell now okay
anything what it what are you into I
mean My Chemical Romance to use like
what are you describe your aesthetic I
mean on I like to wear black I like I
like my Chemical Romance I like to wear
my control men's band band t-shirts I
like I like tight jeans I like jeans
with holes in them what what what
bothers you I mean when people interrupt
me that bothers me but it doesn't matter
sarcasm is funny what bothers me is like
preppies you know and also like well my
CD player skips on the bus because we
hit a bump or something that sucks a lot
or like if like when my friend gets in
my eye like not when it's over my eye
but when it gets like actually pokes my
eye yeah that [ __ ] sucks don't tell
my mom I'm cussing by the way okay is
emo straightedge or not No
not mutually exclusive no it's just a
lot of people like to say they were you
know like it's it's a hardcore
straightedge usually is what they would
say they'd be like yeah I'm hardcore
straightedge or something like hardcore
straight straight it just means that you
don't do any drugs any any alcohols any
of that right I mean emo means that
you're emotional that you maybe listen
to music like makka mukarrama and just
feel it you know like when he hits those
notes and ghost of you you're like yeah
Gerrard you're talking to me and you're
actually my dad and we should be buddies
and you should at reply me I still tweet
of this day my dude because you're only
one emotion you're only like sad or
depressed that's what this is not and
they'd see that isn't that's where they
got emo wrong back in the days I used to
always criticize that and say yeah I am
emo and and I'm I can also be happy
about it cuz that is an emotion as well
and yeah I'm the happiest emo you've
ever seen look kids book I would read
the happiest emo you've ever see that's
just my memoir that's me
oh yeah that's pretty great oh yeah
that's me though what was when you were
like in your full emo state what was
your routine what was your plan for when
you got dressed like what is the look
okay top to bottom or bottom to top I
mean it's your choice cool emo world I'm
just living in it we'll start at the
feet first off we got ourselves like
some adidas Sambas you know or or we
have our van slip-ons
okay don't be silly don't get the plain
color you want checkered and then when
you get older you grow up into a plain
color yeah and then you've got your
pants that are so [ __ ] tight you like
everything is showing but you know what
it doesn't matter because I'm not that
huh
and so you just like wears some tight
pants and they've got like holes in them
and they're like a little faded and you
just feel like a million bucks and then
you wear boxers from American Apparel
that you can definitely see yeah
in the pants then you're gonna wear
yourself it's gonna look like a it's
gonna look it's gonna be a belt but it's
gonna look like a clip from like in a
car like a seatbelt yeah it's gonna look
like
one of those belts and it's not actually
even gonna be holding up your pants it's
just gonna be in there and then you're
gonna have a study built on top of that
oh my god you're gonna have a shirt on
that's one size too small with your
favorite band or ironically your
favorite band that's your parents
because that's cool too that was cool
too okay and then you're gonna get a
flat iron you're gonna straighten your
hair and then you're gonna straighten
your hair again cuz it wasn't right
you're gonna straighten in and when I
say your hair I mean all of your hair
your bangs decides the the little bits
that are about your body hair your hair
you're gonna you're gonna straighten
everything out really set aside a few
hours in the start of the day to get
this look yes yes you're gonna need to
have a fully charged digital camera for
the day for those selfies that you're
gonna take oh yeah cuz you don't have a
phone for your myspace self yeah it's
just for when you're ready and for lunch
when you don't eat in the lunch room
when you eat in the computer lab and you
are there taking pictures of your
girlfriend Allison so it's it's just a
really cool fun time it's a really
casual look oh oh and you knit a black
hoodie that zips up mom has like a hood
on it that's just too large just a
little too large people be like what's
going on with that person and wear it as
much as you can in class got it yeah
oh and hairspray you need hairspray to
keep all that hair in place cuz if you
don't have hairspray it's like what are
you even doing this is a
high-maintenance look trust me so I had
to give it up yeah it was too expensive
I couldn't do it anymore that lifestyle
like a Beverly Hills housewife at that
point mo TM was expensive and don't even
don't even get me started on Alliance
trademark okay I'm sorry
I just didn't know why it's after emo
cuz they asked oh I saw the tweet no I
yeah like emo trademark like I've done
it so much that it's just basically me
okay wait yeah did you ever do guyliner
you'll never know it's no documented
proof of it maybe look I had a myspace
for a long time and I'm really glad a
lot of those pictures are not around
anymore do you really think that they're
not available let's not push it
I'm just gonna suggest if you guys like
that a little bit of free time and want
to do some deep diving and maybe unearth
some
those old photos please don't
I would not disapprove I do strongly I
would not be disappointed never the
findings my owner I'm not gonna lie to
you grace there is a picture of me
dressed up as Gerard Way somewhere on
the way and I got so much makeup on my
face and our anger and my family was
like what's wrong with you and I was
like I'm just being expressive okay I'm
being emotional I'm in touch with my
emotions now I'm gonna go upstairs
listeni under oath and think about all
my future tattoos now if you guys don't
leave me alone I'm going to freak out
and cry okay and then it's gonna be
dashboard is there infighting in the
email community is there like a sense of
judgment between fellow emos like if I
saw another emo person yeah and you were
late and I was in my email face know
that no it was it a sense of camaraderie
it was full family it was like oh you're
one of me it's like Juggalos yes exactly
like slightly let's make up someone Oh
what is the thing you do often that is
very quote your hometown what's the
noise okay I think my just my voice like
every time I go somewhere and there's
like a local from LA they're always like
I love that accent and I'm like what
accent are you [ __ ] talking about
yeah I've never noticed an accent cuz
you're from Ohio yeah well I don't know
and I don't know other than drew Carey
what is Ohio's like stereotype cows
that's it like country like a like tip
and cows and you know corn fails I'm
just like that's like straight up
Midwest just Midwest you know we're just
right there just yeah hanging and
hanging out about Kentucky you know
might be go to the WWV and fireworks and
I you know go down to the baguettes but
is that hovering sounds where you're
from
some people sound like this some people
just like it's a little like is that
kind of like that it's almost like
they're talking to themselves like
they're questioning the whole thing yeah
they always look like they just ate a
lemon yeah and then there's kind of this
like mine where it's this like middle
area and I can't I can't do the middle
middle where it's like every once in a
while they let it slip up where it's
just like where I would be like yo you
can come back
uh-huh where you be like what did you
say y'all to me yeah ironically yeah and
I'll sometimes say y'all when I'm drunk
and I'll be like ooh y'all with a super
southern not Ohio that's it I would
assume that Ohio's more like Bobby's
world like don't you know oh no no no no
no no that's like that's a that's no
that's another word that's a no again
yeah we're more just like where do we
want to be cool we want to sound cool
and you just can't well person from Ohio
just cannot sound cool yeah we don't
have a flow to our voices like even
right now like if some were to
transcribe this they'd be like where's
the punctuation and that's what happens
a lot when they get things transcribed
so what's the most oh hi oh then you do
now if there is something I'm trying to
think of myself for Jersey I feel like
maybe dye my roots or let my roots go
undyed for too long also bagels yeah
maybe make my commitment to a good
breakfast
if someone's I mean I mean it was
important meal the day they're there so
we got a lot of cracker barrels and it's
a big deal and like if anytime I go home
I'm always like here's my menu Juanita
that's my grandmama was like I have this
in the morning on Monday and that on
Tuesday and that on Wednesday and was
like I'm yeah it's like that just that
food you know feel like that's like the
one thing yeah I mean it's a lot where
I'm just like oh yeah yeah some 101 they
think the title should be it's that time
of the month with Mitchell Davis Oh
which I kind of like you know we're
testing these out and they want to know
do we have any memorable st. Patrick's
Day stories oh man this will come out on
April Fool's Day which I've officially
cancelled this year you've canceled it I
can't
I said this year we just all don't need
it you know I mean can we all come into
agreement that's just like we've already
had enough [ __ ] this year we're good
with the way the world is working right
now I feel like we should just stop just
skip it maybe change it into a day we're
all like genuinely nice to each other
with no ulterior motives that'd be fun
because then nobody would really be out
you know you can only have the place to
yourself and if you did actually sounds
great the opposite of the purse let's
pitch that movie yeah it's called the
nice guys out yeah I mean just people
genuinely saying hi and helping each
other like needing any sort of
compensation no just people treating
each other with respect
two and a half pound for two and a half
hours starring the rock Dwayne Johnson
and Kevin Hart yeah that's the two
nicest guys out you'll ever meet fools
pranks I don't like praying God that I
can think of yeah I really hate April
Fool's and I've always I've done the
fake obvious easy low-hanging fruit go
to of a YouTube video where I say I'm
pregnant yeah I've never even done
anything like that the only YouTube
video I've ever put up about pranks is
literally how to deal with people who
are trying to prank you and it's it's a
video of me telling you how to walk away
from these people quickly it's a five
second video of you just walking
actually it's like it's pretty long
because I give you different I'm like
this prank for this this is the prank
for that if they're trying to be like
this you just say this that's great I
genuinely don't remember any of the
words in the video that's why I had to
go like that I don't
it was during this it was during like
the times where it was like gotta make a
video this week gotta make a video this
week gonna make two videos this week
[ __ ] it four videos this week I make a
video I'm gonna start three more
channels one for gaming one
for makeup and one for my family
blogging brands yeah it was amazing to
not missed this is my channel where I
just cracked my knuckles I hope you
enjoy it I remember one of my
ex-boyfriend one time he's a comedy
writer and he came around when we I
think it was for Hannah's birthday she
would have she started calling it like
Hannah would she call it like Hannah day
or something and so she got all of us
like a comped room at the W Hotel and
then she wanted to go to Jumbo's clown
room and I remember Olga Kay came and
Harley was there and it was like this
first time that this guy that I was
dating like meet my content creator
friends and he told me the next day I
guess talking to Olga and I was like so
you do YouTube like tell me what that's
like she goes I have eight channels I
upload 28 videos a week it was like I
was like she's not wrong that she was
doing that at that time which was
commendable and also anxiety and makes
me feel crazy insane I know that's
amazing I'm impressed
Olga Kay I'm impressed okay get those
moosh walks man but yeah he told me that
I was like yeah I know that that sounds
insane to you as someone that doesn't
understand this world but that's very
accurate as to what she does everything
yeah it really was it really was it is I
mean you know it's all just jumbled
together do you have any more memorable
st. Patrick's Day stories you know I
have never been to Jumbo's clown room
ever it's a strip club light it's like
it's more like they all have sticks and
gimmicks and they don't get fully nude
and it's like dancers come out yeah yeah
it's my speed for strip clubs because
I've never been to an actual strip club
before also the first time we went Greg
from Dharma and Greg was just chillin by
himself at the bar and he seemed to know
he L all the dancers on a personal level
so crowded that you had to buy their
merch that they would let you in cuz
there's a line out front they know what
they're doing cool and we all bought
merged because it was how Hannah Kahn
that's what she calls it her birthday
and her used to this
in the last Hana come because we all got
a little too fun and I woke up in the
shower and I didn't want to eat them
publicly so I just sat in the shower
eating almonds so shit-faced and then I
fell asleep with my hand in I was like
well this is horribly like an entire
plastic carton of almonds in the shower
it is on the floor just sleep makeup
smeared and everything is if I just
gotten broken up with there's no reset
that wasn't even st. Patrick's Day oh
the worst empathic stay situation I had
was that same guy that was dating his
friends lived in Denver and we went to
visit them in their new place that they
were living Denver altitude insane and
it was also st. Patrick's Day so we
started drinking green beer like first
thing in the morning all the way to the
night where I remember they we saw River
Dan Irish dancers at one of the bars and
I was just rooting them on so hard like
to the point that you would think that
they were all my little sisters reality
is that I'm just like a 25 year old
woman screaming at them from the side
sloshing a green beer I'll be like okay
that was what I was gonna say is I I've
never had a st. Patrick's Day kind of
thing but know me we have the college
town that I grew up we have green beer
day
oh really him and that's not that's
different than it was a different day
and on that day I didn't subscribe man I
don't remember those days that was the
only time I've ever had green beer and I
know that I can remember but the only
time I've ever blacked out it I don't
know what it is about a cartoonishly
colored beer that makes you think this
has no effect on me I can drink 20
I know what it was for me welcome home
and it changed my to cut my tongue color
like a mirror I was like I'm just man I
woke I woke up and I didn't I this it
was not sexual ready I just woke up in
someone's dorm room I didn't even go to
that school you found a bed for yourself
yeah and I and I and then the next day
it was like sprinkling rain just me like
stain green around my mouth and I just
walked home in the rain and my roommate
Kyle was just like dude where the [ __ ]
have you been and I was like I don't
know dude I don't even know how it
happened did what happened it was yeah
no that's we drink green beer all day
long and then we went back to their
apartment place that they're living and
the friend was like a really he's really
into like cocktails and like excited
about like gin cocktails and making
stuff and we were going back and this
was like you know cut to 12 hours later
stumbling back to their place and him be
like what do you guys want to drink I'll
make us some like cool cocktails and I
just said gin in a cup the altitude
[ __ ] me so hard that the next day I
literally just laid facedown on their
living room floor for the entire day I
was like I feel like death you made it
to be close to the earth I was like I
can't if I stand up everything spins I
have to I live on the floor now
literally that's the callback we've been
waiting for we got that it only took a
hundred and seven episodes we got there
we're gonna get more into these
questions we take another quick break
but when we get back more with Mitchell
Davis out of the floor on not too deep
[Music]
too deep this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by roommate for insulated
coolers for slim and Kraft cans two
canteens that keep a full bottle of wine
at a perfect temperature for over 24
hours brew mate ensures that every sip
of your favorite adult beverage is just
as refreshing as the first no matter
where life takes you and with over 30
color options including matte glossy and
glitter finishes there's something to
match your drink of choice not to
mention all brew mate products are glass
free zone friendly and don't require any
ice you simply pour it in put it in your
bag and go wherever you'd like no more
half drunk beers diluted cocktails or
wasted bottles of wine and guys ok I
gotta admit you know me I'm a little bit
of a lush just a bit so this is a
perfect mashup to be sponsoring this
podcast I went on the roommate offered
me some products I went on and I got
there holographic holographic god I
think I've indulged my brew mate flask
before I recorded this ad read the
holographic glitter spirit flask in
stainless steel it's okay I used to
think flasks were dumb um this one's
perfect it's got it's like slate so it's
like kind of adult and mature I'm asking
them it's also holic I can't even say
holographic so it's pretty when the
light hits it it also has this like
bedazzled top to it and I for sure use
it it when I was down at South by
Southwest in the recent weeks and it was
amazing I it was great I loved it it
kept my vodka cold and it kept my
suspicions minimal so right now brew may
is giving our listeners a special
discount of 15% off your first order
when you go to www.att.com/biz
the summer heat this summer get
tene percent off your first order by
using code grace @br you m8te comm code
grace we're back with more of your
questions for Mitch Davis save us Davis
the same person reigai in nine one five
wants to know what advice would you give
to someone who is normally the wing man
or wing person for others but has a hard
time dating on their own uh that's me I
don't know I guess I need that I don't
know I you are defined by default a good
wingman for yourself I'm a good wingman
for people that write that but I don't
know I have no idea I'm nervous I don't
know
I'm sorry reigai you've asked too many
questions already one one per person we
can't be given reigai too many questions
well then if you have any specific
answers for Mitchell now no no no no
just terrified me yeah I think the
biggest thing is you have to find
someone that becomes your wingmen yeah
yeah and I build you up you need a hype
man I think it's also good if it's a
like a yin yang situation you can kind
of go back and forth and be like yeah I
got you this type it's like hey help you
write take shifts
sure yeah turn it into a work
environment actually start a career yeah
maybe get a job just get a job that's
the answer okay rain tranquillity gave
us some rant topics rain tranquility
gave us things to rant about yeah I love
it yeah what a weird juxtaposition yeah
ran topics pet peeves pet peeves what's
your biggest pet peeve Oh eating in
silence I think I hate hearing someone
eating like I hate when someone's like
here's your food like they like well
there's like a just dinner and like
someone's house or something and they
all put the food down and [ __ ] and then
everyone just starts eating is just the
sound of just like its sketch right it's
just literally silverware and then like
one sentence gets it and then everyone
goes back to like like even the moments
like when I'm in ship Oatley and the
music is cutting to another song and it
takes just a little too long I'm like
everyone stop eating
haha everyone acknowledges moment of
silent a haven't started playing the
next song and I can hear are you
smacking your mouth I [ __ ] hate it
and even this morning I was eating a
granola bar and I was like cuz I was
listening to the rain cuz I'm that guy
yeah that guy and and the rain stopped
and it got silent enough for a second
that I heard myself eating the granola
and you made yourself mad I was like I
gotta turn on music I'm so disgusting
literally that's what I mean I said it's
just oh oh it's the worst so [ __ ]
worst why would you even bring this up
practice rain tranquility background
what's your baby well I get that because
when I got a Sonos system I play music
in my house like all day long like as a
background stuff if I'm not watching TV
and so I'm so we used to have any
background noise they're having like
white noise in some way then if I get
into an uber if I go over to someone's
house or something and there's no sound
in the background not even just like a
fan or something yeah I literally I'm
just like I can hear too much
claustrophobic
yeah really I don't know I there's
something about it I just really gives
me the [ __ ] it like on on airplanes
it happens to me a lot sometimes in
there now snacks and [ __ ] and there's
like no sound whatsoever and all I can
hear is the people eating I'm just like
we got to wrap this it's great you guys
brought this on the plane yourselves but
you got rap okay I think my pet peeve
one is just people being mean to other
people that's general big that's okay
that's mine too I guess yeah sure I
don't know who enjoys dead people that
don't use their turn signals I haven't
getting real pissed about this lately
and I don't under it's the only way our
cars communicate with each other why are
you not utilizing communication you know
I think about the lack of communication
between cars all the time because it's
like I have no other way to tell you
what I'm about to do in this death
machine on wheels that I'm operated that
is why I cannot wait and I find it so
goddamn important that we need to start
like amp
meeting more electronics and not like
check out this display or this it's just
like cars need to be able to communicate
via bluetooth like how close they are
yeah it's kind of like they need proxies
and I just yeah cuz I got a Wrangler now
I upgraded from Wrangler
I got Jeep Wrangler I have a Mini Cooper
someone from travel go-kart to like a
yeah
doofy golf cart situation yet you
literally just it's the same car but
just like me but has a beeping sensory
system that when I get too close to cars
on either side if I'm trying to change
lanes it lets me know super thankful
yeah it screams at me a little bit of
chirps at me and tells me no no not yet
I look I remember the first time I ever
got into a car that that started beeping
and dinging when you didn't buckle your
seatbelt and I was like okay clear okay
yeah cars can go in the right direction
I've just been waiting for the day that
I can have an uber that's just like
self-driving and it's all just like
bluetooth you know smell shaking her
head like I don't want that but I want
that I want that so terribly please car
gods yeah I think lately my biggest pet
peeve is no turn signals I just get so
mad especially because they're literally
it's just so easy a click honestly I
turn mine on all the time on accident I
turn it on when I'm going straight I
like to freak everyone out the opposite
way you know when I was when I was okay
this is so [ __ ] stupid my days
younger I used to do this thing where I
would turn the hazards on when no one
was paying attention and see how long it
took someone who to see how long whoever
was driving yeah I genuinely thought it
was [ __ ] hilarious I did four years
Wow because my caught my old car that I
used to share with a few people just
have like a big hazard button in the
middle that's what they usually do and
so I was just like I would like someone
won't be making a turn or like a I don't
know they would just be like pulled in
somewhere and I would just like just
slow it really quiet and and so until
yeah like in between songs you'd hear
like a oh yeah and it'll be like what
the [ __ ] Mitchell I used to do this
same thing with Nickelback any time I
would be playing on the radio and I
found in literally it says if you said
that you abuse it and so because I would
like beer on Radio duty while the person
is driving and so if I'd find a
Nickelback song I would I would just be
really quiet and just slow like every
few minutes just like like what are you
I was playing too many April Fool's
jokes and cars you were total prankster
other people's and people leave their it
turn signals on my accident I know
that's not by accident in the cops
Mitchell's just driving in an uber a
little silly guy and I should I should
start doing it new burr see how quick my
rating goes that you can read people's
reviews of the uber driver no but that's
what I'm writing now I didn't know
what's the thing my brother called it an
uber for all of us and he goes someone
commented on this driver and just goes
they're a talker like I didn't talk
because he saw that one time and went
well now I can never [ __ ] talk that's
like I secretly want to do cuz it's not
a mean thing you're not in saying
anything totally negative you're just
like inferring that this might be
uncomfortable you don't like talkers and
that's now what I want to leave as a
comment on all this guy's a real talker
we got a chatterbox over their hands
over here five star ride five star
conversation yeah big human radio radio
DJ driving the Nissan really detailed no
ox court needed yeah okay the rain
tranquility also wants us to rant on the
reality of being a youtuber I want you
to go first on this one the reality is I
don't consider myself a youtuber right
now yeah me neither me neither
like YouTube is a platform that I use
but the word youtuber I doesn't exist
I don't know something I heard
I know tick talkers everything oh yeah
we're all cashing right now we all tick
tocking right now I mean that's a shock
you don't stop I I hope but I hope that
somebody goes wow we really should
because on the platform here this and
there's just like a marketing guy and
he's like [ __ ] why have we done this
yeah I think she's been brushing our
teeth the bottle of Jack for days I
think I heard Hank green say something
that like really affected me like hit a
chord he said something I forget where
was that where it's basically the same
type of question like what advice would
you give for someone starting YouTube
and he was like my advice is null and
void now like the way that I started on
YouTube has no relevance to the way
people are starting now so my advice is
not helpful yeah you know what that and
I was like that's great sound like
bullshitting some you know thing not
transparency and authenticity and like
consistency you're just like no I can't
actually give you advice because I don't
know how the [ __ ] to do it yeah I mean
those are the rules you know ten years
ago five years ago and it's it's a
totally different ecosystem now nobody
it's less a community and more business
oh for sure I mean and that's what
happens with any company or organization
that's trying to grow and it is Google
you have to understand that it's it's
Google with a fun little filter that's
called you - yeah but it is just Google
it's it's algorithms and [ __ ] like that
and and now that they have like kind of
know what it is and are trying to
harness bits of it yeah it's a lot more
isolating and it's a lot more like
you're saying not community based but
more like it's a brand I'm working on a
plan it's a lot more structured in terms
of like there is natural playbook yes
how to do it now yes like I'm used to
make the joke that there is no rulebook
for us and no actual tangible robot yes
there is now and there's like weird
animals teaching you how to do it better
an oddly my like I don't know I don't
wanna be controlled by the man
personality and my brain is like
rebelling against that
like sure you got a rulebook but ya
ready to follow those rule books but
then I'm like why are my numbers bad
like Oh cuz you're not going by the rule
but the rule book is is it's really it's
really intimidating yeah
whereas it didn't used to be like that
like when you were uploading something
you were just praised for making
something yeah as where now it's just
you it's very active that that was bad
that was not a good thing that you
uploaded and we don't like that and
here's exactly how you can change so
that you're good again it's like here
like oh and I thought you're my biggest
per viewer out of this crazy and I
thought that you liked me for me yeah
and it's that's like a thing now a lot
there's a lot more of like we better get
what we paid for you know what kind of
vibe I feel and yeah it's a it's a
bummer because it does obviously give
people a pathways to create content more
so than ever but at the same time
I feel like it makes everyone
cookie-cutter versions of everyone else
that the authenticity has gone away
because everyone's going by these quote
rules rather than being like themselves
yeah I honestly I would say that if
you're trying to be a quote youtuber
right now you're doing something wrong
yeah that's that's not like a that's you
that should just be a branch to the root
of whatever something is that you say
not to be an old crotchety dumbass right
now but like no your was a couple years
ago the idea of being a youtuber was a
genuine possibility that could happen
for people and people like the lives of
coaches of the world like we sought it
out and did it
yes and now that doesn't work anymore
yeah no I mean it's like someone being
like waking up tomorrow being like hey
I'm gonna be a vine star yeah you know
to me it's like I get the vines on
around anymore but technically it is cuz
it's on Twitter and it's all on a go
yeah so it's just like but no I'm
serious it's just like this the same
things and it's I don't know yeah it's
really hard to I I just wouldn't want to
put myself in such a it's such a small
box now it is
super used to be really bast and now
it's just like oh you so you do that I
know there's there's jokes about that
industry which means to me it's an old
industry now if people like there's that
new movie coming out called the other
two I think it's called with the
siblings who's like younger brother
becomes like a Justin Bieber like
sensation and it's like them that are
it's the show yeah it's from the writers
of SNL I think did it it looks really
[ __ ] funny I think that mission for
it which is a bummer but it's yeah and
then it's like the two older siblings
are like hot messes in their own regard
and so it's like them going to Hollywood
with their little brother but like
that's funny and there's a scene that I
saw Tyler posts where it's like the
older brother at the party talking to
people me like what do you guys do and
they're like oh we're influencers we're
like gay influencers like what does that
mean like we make content he's like what
he's like
I do like lifestyle he does like
religion he does this and it's so stupid
but it is that's how it is now like oh
man this sucks if it's now able to be
parodied like that it's uh it definitely
means that it's old its old yeah it's
definitely gone through some phases if
we make next what's next tick tock is
that what we have to look forward to it
give me a rock I'm taking myself out now
I don't know what's next I I mean I and
I think that's like the beauty of the
internet we don't know what's next cuz
if we all did like it would already be
[ __ ] ruined but that's all YouTube
was was like this thing that was I felt
like a little private lost space that a
bunch of us got to like hang out and and
go oh here's our like little oasis that
no one really knows about and the people
that don't really know it are judging it
but they don't know how fun it is and
now it's just like yeah someone opened
up all the doors and like all of the
sides just [ __ ] all over yeah I mean
I definitely think the next thing it's
it's it's gonna be about going back to
that community vibe yeah I think it's
gonna cycle back where it's almost
fingers crossed where yeah where it's
almost kind of like the way people are
using patreon and yes these kind of
sites where it's just like I'm actually
just gonna make the content for the few
people that enjoy
yeah and I'm gonna and I'm fulfilled
with that and I'm not gonna look at
numbers or anything yeah I agree I think
it really excites more towards where my
brain leans now it's like the being able
to do the podcasts and like speak
directly to an audience without trying
to be this like broad mmm
sort of appeasing situation instead
doing it for myself and the people that
truly like are engaged with they care
about it is way more fulfilling to me
than being like I just want to pass
three million subscribers or whatever
yeah yeah and it's also it's just it's
it's it has more last it has more
longevity if it's not some pop-culture
reference that in two months the videos
unwatchable because nobody it doesn't
make any sense
totally and I feel like a lot of stuff
on YouTube now is that it's very timely
things are very like it's it's it makes
sense today and then tomorrow it's like
it's either old news or it actually
doesn't make any sense anymore
what's the Momo challenge what's that is
that scare is a scary face face okay I
mean this won't even be relevant but I'm
pretty sure I saw on Twitter she knows
it's not actually her right and I look
use what he decreased some yet world
folks it's not actually happening so
yeah there you go
I think yeah he like put it out there
this earned Phil DeFranco also I don't
know he put something interesting though
he I think Phil DeFranco pretty sure
this is what he treated he treated a
video talking about how like the moment
challenge it shouldn't be like it's
harmful for kids or whatever I don't
know what the context of this challenge
is I know it's a scary little face thing
yeah so he posted this video being like
this is why the Momo challenge is like
bad or wrong there's no no challenge
it's a no no challenge and then YouTube
promoted his video being like Thank You
Phil for like uncovering this but then
they also demonetized his video of him
telling people the reality of this
challenge it's welcome to YouTube was it
a screenshot of YouTube retweeting his
video and then the screenshot of him not
being monetize Nico's like a story in
two still frames I mean that is such a
that is all that's beautiful that should
be published it's a two page book that's
funny it's very funny and also like ah
that's sad yeah I got a copyright strike
on party music to a couple days ago
party music - yeah that's ten years old
you've been demonetised for a hundred
words to call your vagina I saw this oh
man that was great I in some I think
someone everybody was like you got a
frame this and I was like you put that
in your bathroom that's funny a random
email came up and I was like really it's
taking guys this long that's right
that's what seriously there's still I
got the hole in my sock and life is over
uh-oh we've almost gotten to the end of
the podcast and I was gonna say the last
little thing that green Tranquility
wanted us to rant about was holes in the
sock the expectation society has for
people who are in their late 20s early
30s and the expectation is that we're
all perfectly never [ __ ] together but
clearly holy sock McGee is living proof
that we're all relatable Millennials are
running around like chickens with their
heads cut off and then gen Z is watching
it all burn okay y'all a little extra
you guys have started making because you
got all excited about being content
he's like we'll make change you guys
just keep taking your [ __ ] selfies
and your 50 promote that we're gonna
work on some gun lobby laws real quick
we're actually writing things do you
know what writing is have you read a
book or using our platform for social
change that's just social media but good
luck with that
audible brand deal yeah really love that
baby shark song is really cool thanks so
much for that it really is something we
love playing well we're already studying
you guys are really the future health
care reform
[Laughter]
that is funny though on that note
Mitchell thank you for joining us for
the first formal monthly episode of to
be determined named podcast featuring me
we gave them plenty of options keep
tweeting at us options that you think
would be helpful for these episodes yeah
to delineate them and also you know
we're gonna continue to figure out like
the exact format for this this one's a
little loosey-goosey yeah they might
just want to stir anthem I just want to
do cue cue a knows you don't know might
just want us to be cute this is like
some weird terrible nails on the
chocolate bar oh I'm sorry she to be
like this everyone where can people find
you online if they don't already know
Mitch I live lava live TV and CD emoji
calm and just at Mitchell Davis two M's
two else two S's you got it on all
social media platforms yes it's just
everywhere we'll see you guys next time
another episode of not your deep Thank
You Mitchell goodbye too deep toady
codeine
not too deep cry static not too deep is
a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer and edited by
melissa demons writing by diane kang a
production assistants by Katrina Henning
post production sound by Christopher
Bell and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]